dans l'actualité ce soir la birmanie en
plein chaos le dernier bilan du cyclone
s'élève à plus de 60 mille morts et
disparus
l'aide humanitaire est acceptée mais la
junte au pouvoir veulent à distribuer
elle-même en france les larmes de michel
fourniret qui a craqué pour la première
fois depuis le début de son procès le
tueur en série présumé était confronté
aux témoignages de ses proches son frère
évoque une double personnalité
une visite dans le gard sur le thème de
l'emploi et des retraites nicolas
sarkozy a passé une journée anniversaire
plutôt discrète un an après son élection
il reçoit en ce moment les ministres et
leurs conjoints à l'elysée
le coup d'envoi des négociations sur
l'assurance chômage les syndicats
rejettent l'idée de conditionner
davantage les allocations le
gouvernement lui parle d' échanges
fructueux
enfin la face cachée des jeux d'argent
l'addiction est reconnue désormais comme
un problème de santé publique
les casinos s'adapte on verra que les
hôpitaux aussi c'est le dossier de cette
édition
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous les ravages
engendrés par le cyclone en birmanie
sont comparables à ceux du tsunami il y
a trois ans et demi c'est ce qu'affirme
une organisation humanitaire qui a
survolé le pays
c'est bien une vague géante qui est à
l'origine de la plupart des victimes de
nouvelles images tournées au moment de
la tempête nous sont parvenus
aujourd'hui claude sans père
voici les premières images amateur
tournée samedi dernier lors du passage
du cyclone
nous sommes à rangoun l'ancienne
capitale
la personne qui filme se trouve en haut
d'un immeuble quelques instants plus
tard l'homme descend au niveau de la rue
et films depuis un parking impossible
d'aller plus loin
les vents soufflent à plus de 200
kilomètres heure ce week-end les
autorités parlé de 300 morts
aujourd'hui officiellement on évoque le
chiffre de 22500 victime est d'environ
41 mille disparus quelques images
aériennes montrent l'ampleur des
destructions
mais très peu de témoignages nous
parviennent la ville de bogolan aurait
été détruite à 95% le seul journaliste
occidental présent birmanie a réussi à
se rendre à beaugas l'aïe dans son récit
il montre les biens et les quelques
aliments qu'une famille a su préserver
autour de lui tout est détruit dans les
reportages de la télévision d'état
on montre l'armée au secours des
populations distribution de vivres d'eau
et de couvertures
dans ce régime tenu par une junte
militaire depuis plus de 40 ans ces
images de propagande cash apparemment
une situation très difficile
à rangoun les activités reprennent peu à
peu mais la vie quotidienne est très dur
il n'y a quasiment pas d'eau et
d'électricité les gens prennent de l'eau
dans les lacs qui parfait mangoune et on
a un petit peu peur avec l'arrivée de la
mousson en plus dans des prochaines
semaines on a cet après-midi le premier
avion des dettes arrivées à rangoon en
provenance de thaïlande pour le moment
celle seules la birmanie officiellement
accepté l'aide internationale mais en
fait elle accepte les colis et ne donne
pas de visas aux équipes humanitaires
en ville les prix se sont envolés l'eau
les sens le riz deviennent des produits
inaccessibles
alors chacun se débrouille comme il peut
mais dans certaines régions on n'a
toujours pas vu un secouriste depuis
quatre jours
et aux états unis george bush a mis en
garde les militaires laissez-nous venir
vous aider dit-il
nous pouvons faire beaucoup plus en
france bernard kouchner indiqué qu'il
souhaitait se rendre sur place mais
qu'il avait peu de chances d'obtenir un
visa pas plus lui que les autres alors
il s'agit du cyclone le plus meurtrier
en asie depuis 17 ans que s'est il passé
exactement
explication nicolas chateauneuf
christophe kenck voici une image
satellier des coudes birmane prise il ya
trois semaines
voici une autre image prise hier entre
les deux des régions entières riche en
rizières sont passés sous les eaux avec
des vents dépassant 200 km ray des
pluies torrentielles cyclone narguis a
libéré une énergie dévastatrice puiser
dans les eaux chaudes du golfe de
bengale et comme tous les cyclones
il est né en mer les conditions une eau
à plus de 26 degrés sur au moins 64
mètres de profondeur l'air se réchauffe
à son tour et créer une dépression qui
tourbillonne l'ouragan se forme il peut
parfois dépasser 1000 km de diamètre
mais en birmanie un autre phénomène a
joué sous le cyclone l'eau a été aspirée
par la dépression créant une sorte de
dôme
ce dôme d'eau se déplace il fait à peu
près de l'ordre de 4,4 m à 3 m 50 de
haut et quand ils arrivent sur les
terres il va inonder les terres
inondations plus fortes précipitations
ça fait des dégâts énormes et au même
moment vous et des vents très violents
donc beaucoup de dégâts et
malheureusement beaucoup de morts depuis
longtemps les chercheurs tentent
d'améliorer leurs connaissances des
cyclones allant même jusqu'à plonger d
avion bourré de capteurs dans l'oeil
cette zone centrale où c'est le calme
plat résultat depuis une trentaine
d'années il recense une légère
augmentation du nombre de cyclones
extrêmement puissant ce qui dégage une
énergie équivalente à 10 fois
l'explosion d'hiroshima quant au futur
les modèles climatiques sont prudents
avec le dérèglement climatique il
prévoit tout de même des ouragans pas
forcément plus nombreux mais aux pluies
plus intense est à noter que l'inde
affirme avoir averti la birmanie 48
heures à l'avancé en donnant précisément
le point d'impact du cyclone l'onu
déplore l'absence d' alerte précoce
à l'autre bout du monde au chili c'est
le volcan chaiten qui menace une
puissante éruption de cendres et de lave
a amené tout à l'heure les autorités a
décrété l' alerte maximum
une évacuation totale de la région est
en cours par voie maritime
un journaliste de la chaîne publique qui
intervenait en direct a dû interrompre
brutalement ce reportage
la couche de sang vous voyez toujours
aussi impressionnante elle ressemble à
de la neige en france
actualité judiciaire d'abord avec le
procès de michel fourniret
après 21 jours d'impassibilité le tueur
en série présumé confronté à ses proches
a fondu en larmes aujourd'hui un peu
plus tôt son propre frère l'avait
comparé un loup garou évoquant sa double
personnalité
dominique verdeilhan mathias secondes
l'air de famille est évident pourtant le
frère de michel fourniret a changé de
nom pour sa propre réputation
je suis écartelé dit il je n'ai pas
envie de défendre un assassin d'enfants
mais je n'ai pas le droit d'attaquer mon
frère c'est un mégalomane tout son
succès basé sur le bluff
il agit par domination et puis soudain
le vieil homme se tourne vers les
victimes
je compatis à votre douleur je pense à
vous si vous avez besoin de quelque
chose je serai toujours là l'instant est
inattendu presque magique
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya quand même un peu
d'humanité dans la famille
c'est le premier témoin qui se tournent
vers nous pour pour un peu nous exprimer
un peu et bien sa compassion et certains
d'entre vous nous ont même dit merci
oui c'est effectivement jean thompson et
j'ai quand même une dame tu peux rien je
suis un mois magistrats et avocats
tentent de faire craquer fournirait en
vain et c'est la fille d'un de ses
employeurs qui parvient tu me fais honte
pour papa dis ce que tu as sur le coeur
fait le pour moi michel fourniret secoué
trouble et fond en larmes
l'orgueilleux que je suis ne te répondra
pas on ne demande pas pardon pour ce qui
est impardonnable consentent à dire
fournir et il aurait été froment
surprenant que michel fourniret
s'écroulant plan et en demandant pardon
c'est pas sûr fait qu'ils pleurent rient
pleurent fourmies
michel fourniret qui refuse toujours de
se livrer en public monique olivier qui
hier évoque du bout des lèvres une vie
monotone sans amour une vie de
soumission face à eux sur le banc des
parties civiles les familles des dix
victimes
elle écoute courageusement il y à des
souffrances qui ne se compare pas la
justice encore pour la deuxième fois en
sept mois interpol lancé un avis de
recherche international sur internet
contre un pédophile
l'homme s'était mise en scène avec des
photos des photos floutées
mais cette fois encore l'organisation a
réussi à les décrypter benoît gadret
thierry monnier c'est l'une des six
photos diffusées sur le site internet
d'interpol
on y voit un homme âgé d'une
cinquantaine d'années un homme soupçonné
d'avoir abusé sexuellement de trois
enfants de type asiatique âgé de 6 à 10
ans nous avons des images avec cette
mission en train de abusé sexuellement
des enfants
on a
un centaine de photos avec ses amis sur
des dents et est donc quelques photos il
est masqué mais dans les autres c'est
très clair ces photos ont été saisies il
ya deux ans en norvège chez un
particulier d'y stocker dans son
ordinateur plusieurs centaines de
clichés mêlant kate n'a pas permis
d'identifier le pédophile
d'où le recours à internet c'est la
deuxième fois qu'interpol fait ainsi
appel au public en octobre 2007 il y
avait eu l'opération vie qu au départ un
cliché truc et que la police avait
réussi à reconstituer après diffusion
sur internet
christopher neil un canadien de 32 ans
avait été interpellé par la police
thaïlandaise
plus de 350 personnes s'étaient
manifestées auprès d'interpol
cette méthode exceptionnelle pour
l'heure seulement utilisé pour les
délinquants sexuels mais elle pourrait
l'être à terme dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
en bref on d'évoquer tiers les filatures
à l'espionnage dont olivier besancenot a
fait l'objet pendant plusieurs mois
la société taser france qui
commercialise le pistolet électrique qui
est en conflit judiciaire avec le porte
parole de la lcr dément toute
responsabilité dans cette surveillance
l'entreprise indique qu'elle porte
plainte contre lexpress.fr qui avait
évoqué cette hypothèse politique ni
faste ni bougies pour nicolas sarkozy
contexte morose oblige le président de
la république a voulu banaliser cette
journée anniversaire un an après son
élection en visite dans le département
du gard sur le thème des retraites et de
l'emploi
il n'a pas voulu évoquer son bilan
alexandre kara stéphane dumont comme un
président en campagne
un an après son élection face aux
ouvriers de cette entreprise du gard
nicolas sarkozy retrouve l'accent qui a
fait son succès le 6 mai 2007
ok regarde il ya une différence sur la
feuille de paye je n'ai pas trop de
contrôles pitt moi c'est pas vrai sur la
feuille de paye sur les heures
supplémentaires ya pas de soustraction
oui ou non
tutoiement pédagogie poignée de main
virile
c'est la recette sarkozy aujourd'hui il
est venu ici plaidé pour l'emploi des
seniors
ceux d'entre vous qui ont cotisé pour
avoir une retraite pleine pourront avoir
leur retraite et prendre un emploi en
plus et cumuler sans limite retraites et
salaires
l'image que le président veut envoyer
aux français est clair qu'à pas de
commémoration de l'action
un bilan suffisamment les commentaires
des commentateurs notre adresse et agir
mag bilan donc mis un cadeau pour les
retraités
toutes les pensions seront revalorisées
de 0,8 pour cent le 1er septembre
prochain
autre signe de sobriété l'ump a réuni à
l'occasion de cet anniversaire ces
nouveaux adhérents ce soir dans un lieu
symbolique la salle gaveau la victoire
de nicolas sarkozy avait été fêté il ya
un an mais le président de la république
a finalement décidé de ne pas s'y rendre
sur place et les nuques virginie travers
retour salle gaveau un an après
dispositif de sécurité intacte les
nouveaux adhérents de l'ump
toujours au rendez vous il y a un an
tout juste nicolas sarkozy venait faire
ici son premier discours de président
élu
aujourd'hui les militants l'espère sans
trop y croire
pouvais pas le dire parce que cela
mènerait la fac à y perdre en douce la
crise de président pour commémorer
l'événement défendre le bilan attaquer
l'opposition ce sont les minéraux qui
monte au créneau
yann on savait qu'ils étaient nus si on
devait faire mieux
eh bien ça a été beaucoup de fonds par
contre parti socialiste a été beaucoup
de son temps à marquer nous inventer des
nouveaux longs entre bling bling et
coiffes quoique voilà c'est la seule
chose de factice qualités-là de
l'extraction du mot pour souffler cette
première bougie
françois fillon n'a qu'un mot à
l'adresse du chef de l'état bon
anniversaire nicolas bon anniversaire
le fier de ne pas être là pour gérer le
déclin tranquille de notre pays mais
d'être là pour redresser la france
et qu'importe l'impopularité actuelle du
tout l'exécutif
le premier ministre s'engage le
président ne changera pas de positif
nicolas sarkozy qui va tout de même
marquer le coup ce soir bonsoir michaël
darmon vous êtes en direct de l'elysée
où les ministres et leurs conjoints sont
invités pour un dîner en famille donc
mais sans caméras
oui tout à fait nicolas sarkozy qui a
décidé très tard dans l'après midi il
faut le savoir de ne pas se rendre
finalement seul gaveau après avoir
beaucoup hésité
et bien reçoit en ce moment donc les
membres du gouvernement avec leurs
conjoints ce qui n'est pas un détail
anodin pour marquer effectivement
l'ambiance décontractée et conviviale
que l'on veut donner ici à ces soirées
d'anniversaire
toutefois c'est également le sentiment
d'avoir maintenant une équipe
gouvernementale réuni autour de lui pour
continuer les réformes difficiles qui
s'annoncent que veut donner ce soir
également nicolas sarkozy avec cette
soirée car l'an ii du quinquennat
sarkozy commence alors que les mots ont
changé on ne parle plus de rupture
on parle de réformes et finalement ce
retour à ce réalisme plus classique
signifie peut-être la fin de cette
hyperprésidence qui a marqué la première
année de nicolas sarkozy à l'elysée
merci michael le parti socialiste a
voulu lui aussi se faire entendre à
l'assemblée nationale
la plupart des questions portaient sur
le bilan de cette première année
par ailleurs un an tout juste après la
défaite j'ai vite imbert et delphine par
icmi l'air ont rencontré ségolène royal
voici le reportage
pas de bougies dans le bureau de
ségolène royal on ne célèbre pas
l'anniversaire d'une défaite même avec
17 millions de voix petit réunion de
fidèles comme un jour ordinaire avec une
hypothèse et si c'est elle qui avait
gagné il ya un an je crois que la france
aurait été sans doute gouverner avec
beaucoup plus de sérieux et d'efficacité
je ne serai occupé des français avant de
m'occuper de moi même ceci mais il faut
montrer ses forces ce matin l'assemblée
jean marc ayrault leur patron donne la
ligne au début des socialistes
jusque je vous propose à tous ceux qui a
un fils rouges sur le bilan
alors apple c'est l'anniversaire on doit
cogner fort et est centrée sur
l'économique le social le pouvoir
d'achat aux mêmes et cet après midi dans
l'hémicycle le ps n'y en a que pour le
chef de l'état
y at il une arnaque y at il eu le fiasco
y at il eu tromperie l'histoire
tranchera
décidément un jour pour faire parler de
soi bertrand delanoë jusque-là
mystérieux dévoile ses ambitions pour la
tête du parti en lançant aujourd'hui
même son site internet
il se trouve que c'est lui mais c'est
pas si mal je vais vous dire parce que
ça prouve que nous devons critique et
nous opposer des formes les français
mais aussi que nous avons un devoir de
leur proposer une alternative front
commun contre le président cela évite
aux socialistes de parler des choses qui
fâchent comme la guerre de succession
en bref les premières sanctions après l
affaire d surirradiation à l'hôpital
d'epinal la ministre de la santé
roselyne bachelot a révoqué le chef du
service de radiothérapie
un autre médecin a reçu un blâme
rappelons que 5500 personnes ont reçu
des doses de rayons trop forte
la santé encore avec la face cachée des
jeux d'argent le sujet a longtemps été
tabou on estime que six cent mille
joueurs sont aujourd'hui en état d'
addiction comme peuvent la provoquer
l'alcool ou la drogue à premier service
spécialisé a ouvert ses portes dans un
hôpital à nantes et la france pourrait
décider de suivre l'exemple de la suisse
où les personnels des casinos sont
formés par des psychologues
c'est le dossier de cette émission il
est signé laurence beauvillard et
francis forget faites vos jeux rien ne
va plus dans ce casino suisse les
joueurs sont tout particulièrement
surveillé
et c'est pour la bonne cause la
dépendance au jeu est un vrai problème
de santé publique pour la prévenir
en suisse on va jusqu'à former les
croupiers le style de jeu machines à sou
correspond assez bien au profil du
joueur dépressif ou n'auraient pas ce
profil de joueur aux tables au tableau
aurait des gens plutôt actif dynamique
et qui pensent maîtriser le jeu qui sait
gagner contre le casino occasion le but
repérer les signes de dépendance aux
machines à sous et c'est souvent la
tendance se retrouve les joueurs de
talent qui ont trop peur de frédéric
soum et psychothérapeute
il travaille pour plusieurs casinos car
cette formation du personnel est
obligatoire sinon le casino peut fermer
cet employé du casino enregistre les
comportements suspecte tout est examiné
noter le temps passe et la fréquence des
visites
les sommes jouées ensuite convocation ou
exclusion peuvent être envisagées on
m'informe que ce monsieur s'est mise en
colère
c'est la 3ème note d'observations que je
reçois ce sujet donc nous allons avoir
avec lui un entretien
en suisse comme en france le rêve c'est
toujours le jackpot
la machine à sous c'est le jeu qui
provoque le plus d'avis ctions une
fascination qui a coûté 50 mille euros
en trois ans à cette femme le temps la
banque plus l'argent le compte plus rien
aux portes
on pense plus à rien rien sur un petit
nuage
dans un état second carrément je me
souviens fallait sur la machine la plus
pouvoir mettre les pièces en pleine nuit
et continuer à jouer
pire le jeu peut devenir une véritable
drogue et détruire une vie avant je vais
beaucoup j'ai perdu beaucoup
j'avais ma petite entreprise ou qu'elle
gym et rory dont la famille comptant
vous c'est malheureux qu'on n'a pas des
joueurs
voit l'argent en france six cent mille
personnes souffrent d'addiction au jeu
dans cet hôpital de nantes vient
d'ouvrir le premier centre d'études du
jeu excessif
ici on connaît bien le profil des
joueurs pathologiques
ce qu'on voit plutôt ce sont
effectivement des gens très modestes qui
ont souvent des difficultés multiples
des problèmes d'insertion une certaine
précarité
pas besoin de courir au casino le jeu
est partout il se nomme pmu ou française
des jeux est là il est tout près de chez
nous ont offert leur avis qu'est-ce que
c'est un hasard qu'on installe des faits
amis dans un bar pourquoi pas chez le
boulanger les pmi pour une bonne raison
c'est que dans un bar tabac et à
l'alcool et l'alcool est un facteur cas
facteurs qui favorisent la désinhibition
qui réduit encore la capacité de
maîtrise de l'inhibition et donc il va
favoriser la consommation du jeu la
recette de la diction les concepteurs de
jeux la connaissent une mise de 1 ou 2
euros
un résultat en quelques minutes et le
rêve de pouvoir gagner des millions
d'euros le ticket d'entrée pour l'enfer
du jeu
l'actualité sociale avec une relance
mitigé pour la mobilisation lycéenne à
pariset entre 1900 et 6000 a défilé
selon les sources
manifestations également dans une
quarantaine de villes de france
notamment ici à poitiers où ils étaient
entre 800 et 1000 le disent nos
correspondants entreprises ayalim
darrigrand image enfin de grenoble où
quelques incidents étaient observées en
fin de cortège
huit personnes ont été interpellées par
ailleurs cette semaine est un peu
particulière pour les parents d'élèves
en raison du pont du 8 mai lundi
prochain sera férié également c'est la
pentecôte
les écoles vont elles faire le pont
réponse ça dépend explication julien du
père et diane richard la journée vient
de se terminer mais pour par onze élèves
de cette école parisienne
l'heure est encore aux calculs sur les
doigts c'est le nombre d'absents qu'on
compte
je sais par la père de ma fille qui sont
pas là resté en vacances à chaque mois
de mai c'est paraît il et pont se
multiplient et l'absentéisme aussi de
plus en la matière il n'existe pas de
règles nationales chaque académie
s'organise comme elle le veut
illustration à paris après quinze jours
de vacances de printemps maternelle et
primaire travailleront ce mercredi au
lieu de vendredi
histoire de profiter du long week-end
jusqu'au lundi de pentecôte
mais voilà pour les parents qui
travaillent il faut s'organiser
je fais pas échangé avec le g13 journée
pour garder les enfants
du côté du rectorat on le reconnaît
volontiers la solution qui fait
l'unanimité n'existe pas alors on tente
juste d'éviter le pire
je suis absolument sûr que si nous
avions laissé un vendredi travailler
après le jeudi 8 mai férié et avant le
week end je pense que l'absentéisme
aurait été très fort nous avons pu le
constater à d'autres époques 30%
d'absence et le record enregistré ces
jours-ci par certaines écoles à paris
seules certitudes à la fin de l'année
les élèves auront eu 36 semaines de
cours et ça dans toute la france et puis
autre information à retenir en vue de la
rentrée des grandes vacances
suite à la fin de l'école du samedi il
n'y aura plus de rentrée anticipée tout
le monde gagnera la classe le 2
septembre
le coup d'envoi des négociations sur
l'assurance chômage les syndicats
étaient reçus pour la première fois sur
le sujet au ministère des finances et
bien il rejette l'idée de conditionner
davantage les allocations après 3 mois 6
mois ou un an on en parlait hier nous
avons voulu savoir ce qu'on en pensait
dans les entreprises
et du côté des chômeurs eux-mêmes
reportage séverine lebrun daniel lévy ce
chef d'entreprise gère des sites de
presse automobile en pleine expansion
il doit recruter dix personnes un casse
tête selon lui des pénuries dans
certains messieurs les commerciaux
très dur à trouver et puis l'été une
opératrice également il multiplie
pourtant les entretiens d'embauché
près de cinq par semaine mais il arrive
parfois que certains candidats ne
semblent pas très motivés g33 exemple
sous les yeux de personnes ayant refusé
un emploi une personne n'habitait
d'ailleurs à moins de 500 mètres l'ici
et elle a refusé le poste en fait parce
que c'était un peu loin
ce sont ces comportements minoritaires
que le gouvernement voudrait sanctionner
un comble pour les principaux concernés
les chômeurs car des offres d'emploi
acceptable selon eux il y en a très
rarement et là on propose des postes
avec des cdd non à 1800 euros net voilà
je suis cadre
j'ai 38 ans j'ai fait 7 ans d'études et
voilà c'est tout vous en voyez peut-être
40 cv par mail par courrier et vous avez
droit peut-être à trois ou quatre
réponses donc les employeurs aussi de
votre sanctionné pour ce spécialiste des
ressources humaines avant de sanctionner
il faudrait surtout améliorer le service
rendu aux chômeurs
ce n'est que si on est capable de
fournir un compagnon de bonne qualité
individualisé qui perd une rencontre
chaque situation que l'on peut en
contrepartie de ces efforts exigés une
application innovante d'emplois
éventuellement mettre des sanctions il
existe déjà des sanctions pour refus
d'emploi l'année dernière 1500 chômeurs
sur près de 2 millions ont été
concernées économie encore avec le casse
tête des finances publiques le
gouvernement l'a souvent évoquée il n'y
aura pas d'augmentation d'impôts pour
faire face aux déficits
en revanche il veut s'attaquer aux
niches fiscales alors c'est un serpent
de mer
il s'agit de ces centaines d' avantages
accordés à des secteurs ou à des
catégories de contribuables
un rapport sera rendu demain valérie le
rouge alain d'ubs à bernis mériaux un
hôtel en martinique un trois pièces à
mayotte ou départ d'une pme à la réunion
il y a l'embarras du choix pour acheter
dans les dom tom et au passage payer
moins d'impôts l'achat d'un logement
pour la location par exemple et
déductibles à hauteur de 40 à 50 % de
son montant
encore mieux investir dans une
entreprise d'outre-mer 70% peuvent être
défalquée de la feuille d'impôt de
niches fiscales
aujourd'hui sur la sellette elle coûte
relativement cher à l'état elle ne
concerne que très peu de contribuables
puisque les opérations sont des moteurs
en nominaux élevé et un contribuable qui
a des revenus très importants peu
l'arrivée a effacé la totalité de son
ardoise fiscale
par ce biais là mais il n'y a pas besoin
d'être millionnaire pour bénéficier de
niches fiscales et réduire son impôt
exemple avec ce couple deux enfants et
un revenu de 100 mille euros par an
montant de l'impôt 12000 euros ou bien 0
avec le sens des affaires
il suffit que le couple salariés une
femme de ménage ou une nounou à plein
temps et ses 7500 euros qui sont déduits
s'ils achètent un petit appartement de
robien ou borloo il peut encore enlever
2000 euros de ses impôts chaque année
pour peu qu'ils placent le reste de ses
économies dans une entreprise innovante
de sa région il pourra défalquer 2500
euros résultat plus rien à verser au
fisc plus de 300 autres niche parfois
très ciblée existe les journalistes
profite d'un abattement coup de pouce
aussi pour les producteurs de truffes ou
les éleveurs de chevaux
résultat des courses un manque à gagner
pour l'état de près de 60 milliards
d'euros
deux informations encore le prix du gaz
devrait encore augmenter pour les
particuliers de 1,5 au 1er juillet ce
sera la troisième hausse en quelques
mois
et puis de nouveau retard en perspective
pour le géant des airs l'airbus a380 le
groupe a envoyé un courrier notamment à
son premier client la compagnie emirates
qui a commandé 58 gros porteurs pour
l'informer de ce risque
la sécurité routière pour la première
fois une grande étude médicale et
publiée sur les blessés graves
elle montre que leur nombre est presque
systématiquement sous-estimer les
accidents de la route font en fait
autant de handicap est lourd
que de morts des vies brisées dont on ne
parle pas souvent
patrice pelé sylvain daube à l'hôpital
raymond-poincaré de garches dans la
chambre 145
mais quelle kader témoigne il est ici
depuis le 12 décembre
ce jour-là à 6h30 alors qu'il se rend à
son travail à moto une voiture le
percute par l'arrière
on a retrouvé 50 mètres à 50 mètres de
mon véhicule
une heure après l'accident parce que
gilles a pris la fuite et le chauffard
n'a jamais été retrouvé michael est en
rééducation
alors c'est rappeler qu'on dit
incomplète parce que je peux bouger mes
bras mes bras bouge et je ne peux pas
bouger mais doit on parle des morts sur
la route 7400 en moyenne par an mais
moins des blessés graves
ils sont pourtant plus nombreux 7500
pour eux rien ne sera plus comme avant
ce sont des lits briser un sens soir des
jeunes en plus lent que ce nous ça nous
surprend pas du tout c'est juste qu'on
connaît bien et pas quelque part je suis
content de voir qu'on s'intéresse enfin
à cette partie là tu es des victimes de
la route
l'étude de l'institut de veille
sanitaire affirme qu'aujourd'hui sur la
route le risque d'être lourdement
handicapée est égal à celui d'être tué
ce qui en réchappent doivent faire face
faut se battre
c'est une question de sa combattre et si
on lâche si on lâche va faire demain la
sécurité routière présentera un nouveau
dispositif de sensibilisation sur la
réalité des drames de la route à
l'étranger nouvelle primaires démocrates
aux états unis dans les indiana et la
caroline du nord les bureaux de vote ont
ouvert leurs portes il ya quelques
heures la nouveauté c'est que la
pression a changé de camp barack obama
est toujours en tête au nombre de
délégués mais il est désormais devancé
dans les sondages par hillary clinton
sur place à indianapolis siège du fameux
circuit alain de chalvron aaron diamond
dans le monde entier indianapolis est
connu pour ça sans circuit automobile et
ses grand prix d'indycar
mais la course d'aujourd'hui la
politique est dans tous les esprits même
chez les républicains
je parie qu obama va gagner et si les
nominés et bien il est possible que je
veux démocrates pour la première fois de
ma vie
obama continue à être le champion pour
le full tilt à thierry hier soir à
indianapolis
ils étaient des milliers sur des
kilomètres à se presser pour le voir
obama comme professeurs des droits j'ai
beaucoup appris je n'ai jamais parlé
personnellement que c'est une de ces
grandes fans
cela n'empêche que le sénateur connaît
un sérieux trou d'air en grande partie à
cause de son pasteur jeremiah wright qui
s'est multiplié dans les médias pour
dire pourquoi il fallait maudire
l'amérique
du pain béni pour les partisans des
vikings le vent a tourné en sa faveur à
la dynamique pour l homme c'est sûr que
l'histoire d'un pasteur de ben hammam
salle a bien neigé chine est inquiète
une grande émotion dans notre il ya
quinze jours barack obama était donné
favori ici dans l'indiana c'est
maintenant hillary clinton en caroline
du nord
il a perdu beaucoup de terrain s'il
devait perdre ses deux états alors sa
campagne sur est en grande difficulté
toujours à l'étranger l'espagne continue
d'explorer son passé avec des
révélations qui vous allez le voir mêle
parfois la grande est la toute petite
histoire un documentaire vient de
révéler que franco était intervenu
personnellement en 1968 finances à
l'appui dessous de table pourrait-on
dire pour assurer la victoire de son
pays à l'eurovision
explication daniel wolfromm marie cros
ben oui mais voilà tout était truqué
et voici ma thiel une partie des voies
porté sur maciel la représentante de
l'espagne franquiste avaient été achetés
résultat la la la tout un programme fut
déclaré vainqueur de l'eurovision mais
le tube espagnol ne perçoit pas au delà
des frontières de la dictature
plus surprenant le vieux dictateur avait
lui-même tout manigancé pour redorer le
blason de son régime franco dépêché en
europe les représentants des télévisions
et maisons de disques espagnols ils
achetèrent des programmes contre des
votes à l'eurovision
voici donc la vaincue notre isabelle
nationale
des mois
en troisième position avec une bonne
chanson quarante ans après elles n'en
revient toujours pas
à satan peux pas croire ça on peut pas
croire qu'on peu de tricher et payer des
gens qui vont voter contre vous parce
que il ya des avantages pensez vous
on ne peut pas y croire dans
l'organisation quand même iliev devait y
avoir un sentiment de culpabilité de
malaise et rien n'a été organisé pour
faire la fête après notre fusion des
fautes le grand favori la star
britannique
cliff richmond en deuxième position du
concours il perd à une voix près cliff
avec l'âme aujourd'hui son dû et la
première place tout le monde a entendu
parler de babylone la cité mythique mais
bien réelle de la mésopotamie avec sa
tour de babel est bien la plus grande
exposition qui lui est jamais été
consacrée est à découvrir en ce moment
au musée du louvre à paris nicolas
lemarignier frédéric faure lumière sur
la tour de babel
elle est le symbole de l'orgueil des
hommes elle a inspiré les plus grands
peintres comme bruegel une tour
gigantesque que les babyloniens voulait
construire pour atteindre le ciel et
égaler dieu selon la bible le mythe de
la tour n'est qu'une partie de la
légende de babylone une ville deux fois
millénaire qui a immortalisé sa
puissance dans la pierre exemple c'est
lyon et ses dragons qui ornaient les
murailles de la cité visible à des
kilomètres à la ronde mains d'yvan est
situé dans une plaine extrêmement 4 et
on voyait donc se profiler des murailles
de la vie est au fond la gaze igora
platanes de ce tour à étages qui
mesurait près de 100 mètres de haut
s'était donc impressionnant babylon est
le berceau de l'écriture l'exposition du
louvre présente le code d'hammourabi une
stèle de deux mètres de haut sur
laquelle sont inscrits les plus anciens
textes juridiques connu et puis sont
présentés les tablettes d'argile qui
évoque la vie quotidienne des
babyloniens l'écriture cunéiforme est
étudiée et déchiffrer depuis deux
siècles
dominique sharpa est l'un des
spécialistes il lui reste encore des
textes à découvrir les 500000 tablettes
n'ont pas tout livré leurs secrets
on n'a pas eu de champollion on n'a pas
eu de campagne d'égypte et donc c'est
vrai que c'est un secteur qui est très
simple et léger on n'est pas un nombre
suffisant pour travailler sur toutes ces
richesses que le perso des civilisations
nous à l'église depuis 2000 ans la ville
gare de son mythe intact c'est ce que
montre aussi l'exposition les peintres
les écrivains les cinéastes se sont
emparés de la cité et babylone a été
incommodé à toutes les sauces
on a adapté babylone d'abord à la sauce
si on peut dire égyptienne puis à la
sauce percée polythène puis à la sauce
assyrienne en fonction des découvertes
archéologiques parce qu'on n'arrivait
toujours pas aux traces exact de
babylone aujourd'hui encore pour le
grand public la cité reste mal connue
l'exposition du louvre devrait réparer
cette injustice faite à babylone la
grande avant de refermer ce journal je
vous en rappelle l'un des principaux
titres la birmanie en plein chaos le
dernier bilan du cyclone s'élève à plus
de 60 mille morts et disparus un premier
avion de vivre s'est posée aujourd'hui
l'aide humanitaire est acceptée mais la
junte au pouvoir veulent à distribuer
elles-mêmes et ne donne pas de visas
georges bush demande à la junte
militaire d'ouvrir ses portes
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko point route valérie
maurice 20h50 un téléfilm sarah
bernhardt une étoile en plein jour avec
notamment
ludmila mikaël à demain
l'info en continu
cette assise sur france 2 point fr